[Musique]
nouvelle édition devait y paie vip sur
tv 78 aujourd'hui avec adeline howart
bonjour bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
danseuse chorégraphe mais viennent ici
dans le département des yvelines on vous
connaît surtout pour votre implication
au sein de la compagnie illicites dance
basée à voisins le bretonneux et puis à
maurepas également et votre actualité du
moment c'est la participation quand vous
en tant que danseuse chorégraphe sur la
tournée de m games week du frigo
tournant c'est bien ces quelques images
tout à l'heure tourne et qui s'est
arrêtée pour l'instant il ya une petite
pause qu'en décembre qui va reprendre
ensuite en mars
comment s'est passée la première partie
de tournée des abers super super
beaucoup de monde des super salle
beaucoup de signer tous les zénith de
france donc donc génial en tant qu en
tant qu'artiste et danseuses on a une
scène on a des musiciens on a un
chanteur qui donne beaucoup et un public
qui présente donc donc que du positif ou
quatre chorégraphes vous avez une
certaine liberté
là pour le coup je ne suis pas
chorégraphe là je suis cadre et de votre
propos des cadres et moi je suis dans ce
je connais mes chorégraphies et voilà
j'ai pas j'ai pas créé les chorégraphies
pour le fait régulièrement sur la route
pour décorer pour des pour des
spectacles en tant que danseuse on peut
être pas si maître gims mais y en a
d'autres aussi complètement est en
voyage on voyage beaucoup c'est aussi
l'un des avantages de notre métier
on peut on visite quelques pays beaucoup
en france mais aussi à l'étranger
c'est pas trop difficile d'être en
permanence sur la route c'est de jongler
avec les autres activités aussi en cours
aux sinon je vais je vais pas me
plaindre c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
un bonheur de pouvoir justement les
visiter des pays peut-être je ferai pas
moi même donc donc c'est l'occasion il
ya une artiste que vous avez rencontrées
vous avez peut-être apprécié on va voir
tout de suite la photo c'était bien
aussi oui bon souvenir c'était pour une
publicité
ça remonte un petit peu maintenant mais
si c'était c'était me semble en 2002
donc sur ça ça nous rajeunit pas ce que
c'est mais oui oui super expérience vie
de travail et qu'une artiste
international comme ça surtout qu'elle
faisait vraiment partie des artistes que
je dois l'être est un petit peu quand
même de par la danse de par2 parce
qu'elle faisait en danse aussi donc oui
super c'est la passion et les artistes
justement qui vous a amené à devenir
danseuse chorégraphe tout qu'est-ce qui
vous a amené un petit peu vers cette
profession et j'ai jamais été fan en
fait vraiment d'artistes cetc
et s'il était la première fois je suis
remonté sur scène en fait c'est le
rapport au public
c'est vraiment ça c'est d'être devant
devant les gens de pouvoir leur donner
et puis la danse c'est vraiment c'est
c'est une forme d'expression et c'est la
mienne donc donc oui c'est je m'éclate
en dansant et c'est vous allez débuter à
14 ans oui badens alors j'ai commencé
même un peu plus jeunes mais dès 14 ans
c'est là que vraiment j'ai commencé à ce
que ça devienne assez intensif quand je
suis arrivé chez illicites dance du cou
ou là c'est devenu de deux fois par
semaine c'est devenu à cette fois par
semaine puis 8 puis 9 puis 10 puis
s'assied pu arrêter du tout parce qu'au
début c'était plutôt quoi c'était alors
l'heure jazz classique elle a un peu hip
hop
non moi j'ai commencé avec le wild au
jazz le classique pour moi est venu
beaucoup beaucoup plus à ça près voilà
après j'ai fait d'abord jazz hip hop
c'est quand même ce que ma spécialité on
va dire hip hop et jazz et après je suis
arrivé au classique parce que
parce que c'est un passage obligatoire
on va dire est que ça amène aussi
beaucoup de choses donc je suis arrivé
beaucoup plus tard alors pour quelques
images des cours des cours au sein du
licite on voit olaf aussi sur les images
qui sont intéressés à l'écran c'est
cette rencontre avec olaf c'est lui
aussi qui a changé complètement en fait
j'ai vu moi pour la première fois il est
si dense à la télé à l'époque j'étais
tout jeune je commençais la danse je
voulais danser mais bon je ne savais pas
trop quoi comment et j'ai vu les siden
gagné graines de stars 199.99 et à la
suite de cette émission j'ai dit c'est
ça que je veux faire et c'est avec eux
que je veux aller et j'ai eu la chance
de sa de 2,2 me rendre compte qu'ils
étaient à côté de chez moi donc dans le
même département et à partir de là donc
j'ai commencé un cours de cours par
semaine et comme vous étiez ça s'est
plus arrêtée par la préfet vous n'avez
jamais quitté la compagnie et j'ai
jamais quitté la paix aujourd'hui vous
donner des cours aussi et aujourd'hui je
donne des compagnies notre une autre
version une autre facette de wuala de ce
que vous faites
l'idée c'est de coincer de transmettre
aussi de créer de rester aussi alerte
sur l'évolution des bras la ccc un petit
peu tout ça principalement moi je suis
né chez les citizens et j'ai envie de
pouvoir retranscrire ça aussi donc faire
de la formation
on a des élèves qui sont qui sont des
enfants on les retrouve en ado puis on
les retrouve en adulte puis certains
gèrent trouve dans le milieu parisé en
tant que danseur donc ça pour moi c'est
vraiment c'est la plus belle plus belle
des choses qu'on va pouvoir les formes
et leur donner tous les mois tous les
tous les moyens pour après se lancer
dans le milieu justement pour se lancer
dans le milieu et faire carrière
c'est compliqué on l'imaginé bien
compliqué on a reçu à l'aps ebe donc le
fondateur dudit site ya pas très
longtemps aussi sur ce plateau et qui
nous expliquait que c'était aussi sa
vocation c'était de permettre au plus
grand nombre d'y entrer parce que les
portes et le milieu est difficile votre
parcours oui difficile oui parce que
parce qu'on n'est pas tout seul quand on
passe des castings on peut être des
centaines voire des milliers
il ya très très peu de place à la clé
donc beaucoup de travail beaucoup
d'opportunités aussi il faut pas se le
cacher
une part de chance malgré tout je pense
que ça fait aussi partie du jeu mais la
base quand même c'est le travail et et
surtout la détermination parce que faut
pas s'arrêter au premier échec en fait
c'est ça qui voit la différence c'est ça
qui fait complètement
il ya eu des échecs en ce qui vous
concerne oui bien sûr été compliqué à
gérer nous et bien c'est remettre en
cause complètement c'est ce qui fait que
on arrête tout de suite on se dit c'est
pas pour moi ou alors non justement je
ne sais pas ça si c'est pas ça ça sera
autre chose et ça sera mieux encore donc
donc l'objectif c'est ce à quoi de ne
jamais lâcher
quel était le moment jusqu'à présent que
qui a été le plus épanouissant le plus
enrichissant pour vous je pense qu'il
n'y a pas eu un moment puisque j'ai eu
la chance de faire plein de choses dans
ma carrière donc plein de choses
différentes dans des domaines différents
donc je m'épanouis autant tant que
danseuse sur scène avec des artistes
canton professeur de danse chez licites
ou avec la compagnie cden soucis aux je
suis chorégraphe
enfin c'est vraiment différentes
facettes et j'ai besoin de tout ça donc
j'ai jamais arrêté lin
j'ai toujours essayé de pouvoir tout
faire comment on se renouvelle aussi en
permanence parce que en tant que
chorégraphe il faut aussi suivre les
évolutions composé d'autres choses bien
sûr faut se renouveler je pense que le
fait de travailler d'être toujours dans
cette activité on
rester à la page entre guillemets on va
dire c'est vrai qu'il faut rester un peu
alerte tout ce qui se passe les modes
oui oui ça a évolué c'est sûr qu'il ya
dix ans et aujourd'hui la danse a évolué
énormément
donc voilà faut je pense que quand on
est dans le milieu est con
on travaille et qu'on rencontre plein de
gens parce que c'est ça aussi on
rencontre plein de danseurs de
chorégraphes de professeurs de sart
enrichi beaucoup et donc ça aide
beaucoup à apprendre en chorégraphe à
pouvoir se couvrir son panel une
démocratisation aussi aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup plus de jeunes qui veulent
s'inscrire et c'est plus facile aussi
pour que ça ne l'était pour vous bien
c'est rock complètement aujourd'hui
c'est devenu quelque chose de
de normal ça fait partie de ces d'un
sport pour beaucoup même si c'est pour
moi c'est plus un art car ce sport mais
oui au même titre que des enfants on
s'inscrire au basket à la rentrée vont
s'inscrire à la danse c'est devenu
quelque chose de banal et ça c'est
plutôt très très bien je parlais de
votre parcours et parcours qui est très
très variés je pourrais aussi parler de
cette expérience aux folies bergères par
exemple voilà une très très belle
expérience
l'appareil gt gt gt à ces jeunes jeudi à
peine majeur
que je suis arrivé propulsé dans ce
milieu du music hall qui le cabaret qui
est quand même complètement autre chose
moi je venais plus du hip hop
donc c'était vraiment quelque chose de
très très très étonnant la première fois
que je ne voulais pas y aller en fait au
début j'avais une vraie appréhension est
arrivé sur cette expérience par un
casting en fait j'étais à l'école j'ai
fait une école de danse haussier à paris
par cette école j'ai passé un casting
pour pour les folies bergères et j'ai
été à vos côtés donc par les folies
bergères pour entrer sur ce magnifique
spectacle est donc au début j'étais
stagiaire puisqu'elle ce format là donc
en tant que danseur à l'école on est
stagiaire donc on fait le même spectacle
que les professionnels mais on apprend
donc donc on est encore à l'école la
journée et le soir sur scène et au bout
de quelques mois j'ai passé de nouveau
l'audition pour cette fois ci passer de
stagiaire professionnel et c'est à
partir de là que je suis devenu
intermittente et que je suis j'ai pu
voler de mes propres et on vivre aussi
et on vivre mieux et que l'on doit plus
difficiles que d'autres complètement
alors j'ai la chance de tabac j'ai
jamais perdu le statut d'intermittente
on va dire donc j'ai toujours bien
travaillé je touche du bois
donc ça c'est vrai que
que c'est passé c'est la clé d'être
constant en fait c est qu il est plus
compliqué dans notre travail c'est que
on a des grosses périodes de travail on
a des mois qu'ils sont un peu plus plus
fort que les autres
les faits par exemple où il ya beaucoup
plus de spectacle le mois de mai juin
avant l'été on est beaucoup plus
donc voilà fois arrivés tout au long de
l'année à continué à travailler et puis
même pour soi pour rester dans une
dynamique de travail peut pas rester
trois mois sans rien faire chez soi
c'est pas c'est pas possible
là tout l'intérêt aussi d'avoir des
cours pour autre chose
comment vous voyez la suite l'évolution
pour vous justement ya un moment où vous
dites va falloir que je raccroche ce
côté-là et complète mais il va falloir
jeu on se le cache pas moi je suis plus
près de ma fin de carrière de danseuse
je parle d'un de deux danseuses que le
début on n'a pas des carrières qui dure
qui dure à 60 ans je vais pas encore
accompagné m gibbs on est bien d'accord
donc donc oui alors la suite j'ai déjà
cette formation chez les sites que je ne
veux pas perdre je veux continuer à
pouvoir former des danseurs et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui me tient à
coeur
donc donc voilà après j'ai encore
d'autres projets qui pour l'instant sont
ne sont pas encore établies j'en parle
pas trop mais il ya plein d'autres
choses encore qui m'intéresse dans le
milieu artistique celle avantage c'est
que c'est très large donc on peut de
danseuses bifurqué sur sur d'autres
évolutions possibles où il ya des
évolutions possibles bien sûr les avais
regrets n'en avaient pas pu faire alors
non j'ai cette chance là je crois que
vraiment j'ai cette chance de
aujourd'hui de me dire que vraiment
gérer j'ai eu la chance de faire un
petit peu tout ce que j'avais envie de
faire alors je dirais que peut-être le
seul regret mais on peut pas tout faire
j'aurais pu un moment donné partir
à partir de france allez allez voir aux
états unis je les fais pour de la
formation mais je n'ai jamais fait pour
pour travailler je me suis pas dit bon
allez je vais voir jeu par un an et je
vais essayer de travailler ailleurs pour
travailler que des artistes
internationaux chose qu'en france c'est
quand même un peu plus limité mais en
fait j'en ai pas ressenti le besoin de
tes je pourrais me dire ça mais c'est
pas un c'est pas un regret pas du tout
pourquoi c'est plus limité en france il
ya plus de choses à faire aussi à
l'étranger ce que on a beaucoup moins
d'artistes en france qui déjà
ce fonds accompagnés de danse condé dans
ses salles américaines
voilà c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
que aux etats unis c'est c'est un
exemple il ya d'autres pays au 6 mai
mais c'est tout un concept veut dire ils
sont nés ça danse ça chante ça joue la
comédie ça fait partie de tout
questionner l'axé culturel exactement
soit en france on a quelques artistes
qui aujourd'hui ont des danseurs mais je
peux les compter sur les doigts d'une
main c'est vraiment c'est vraiment très
peu le modèle tendance aujourd'hui ce
modèle
j'ai plein de modèles en fait qu'est ce
qu'il ya où il ya plein de choses qui
m'intéressent chez chacun donc j'aime
bien prendre un petit peu de donc je
m'entoure des chorégraphes avec qui
j'aime travailler déjà qu'ils
m'inspirent avec qui je peux m'éclater
j'ai pas un modèle précis de la part
d'un artiste que ce que les prétentions
non non pas du tout merci beaucoup a dit
nous d'avoir participé à cette émission
c'est une bonne continuation à vous
aussi bien pour les cours que pour la
suite de cette tournée avec maître gims
qui reprendra en mars à mars et sa merci
beaucoup
[Musique]